legislative filibuster if we confirm
this nominee
now folks they wanted to get rid of the
60-vote threshold long before this
vacancy
on the supreme court ever occurred
again i'll use senator harris by way of
example
quote i am prepared to get rid
of the filibuster to pass a green
new deal
that was in september
of 2019
18 democrats who ran for president of
the united states
supported that move including
six sitting united states senators
and two governors now running for senate
third they've threatened to add
states to the union if we confirm this
nominee
we know that's been on the far left wish
list for years
these idle threats aren't going to stop
us from carrying out the will of the
american people though
and confirming judge barrett
when we confirm judge barrett this week
she will be the fifth woman and the
first mother of school-aged
children to serve as a supreme court
justice
she'll also be the only current justice
to have received a law degree from
an esteemed law school other than
harvard or yale
i'll tell you hoosiers are extremely
proud
of judge amy coney barrett in the trail
she has blazed
for others she's a role model for
young women everywhere including i might
say
my own three young daughters
i'm incredibly proud that our next
supreme court justice will
hail from america's heartland from the
great state of indiana
i urge my colleagues to come together to
carry out the will of the american
people
by swiftly voting to confirm judge amy
coney barrett
to to the supreme court of the united
states
mr president i know the absence of a
quorum
the clerk will call the role mr
alexander
the center's recognized
i request consent that the quorum call
be vitiated without objection
mr president i rise today to express my
support
for the confirmation of judge amy coney
barrett
as an associate justice of the supreme
court she's exceptionally intelligent
academically astute and impeccably
credentialed
she has a record of sound opinions and
temperament as a judge
on the seventh circuit court of appeals
her life experiences provide her with
valuable perspective
and evident wisdom perhaps most
important
she is a woman of unquestionable
character
and integrity the presence of which is
essential to our nation as the
confidence of the court itself
is in the balance i will be honored to
vote to confirm
her nomination mr president i also rise
to address my concern regarding the
division and contempt
for others that is growing among many of
our citizens
the causes of this malady are many and
varied
but one to which i draw attention is the
declining trust
held by the citizenry in our many
institutions
a democratic republic is highly
dependent upon the confidence
of its people in the institutions that
lie at its foundation
these include churches schools
governments at all levels
the press corporations markets and most
relevant today
the justice system and the courts
absent public confidence in these
institutions
a democratic republic will not thrive
or perhaps endure fortunately the
supreme court enjoys a great deal of
respect from the american people
unfortunately the third branch may be
one of the few institutions of our
democratic republic
that is not experiencing a collapse
in public trust our churches have been
diminished by scandal
and by politicization trust and local
law enforcement has fallen as we've
witnessed some officers
who have sworn to protect our
communities endanger the lives of
citizens
while this is particularly true for
citizens of color
the demonstrations by millions of
americans are evidence
that the distrust is broadly shared
trust in the fbi and the intelligence
community
long admired for their integrity and
professionalism
has withered with the attacks by
politicians from both parties
though admittedly my party has been the
more vocal
what a message it sends when the
president accepts the word
of the russian president rather than the
conclusions of our intelligence agencies
even the cdc and the fda have fallen in
credibility
due both to inevitable human error and
to blistering
political attacks the free press
is not only protected by the
constitution it's critical to the
preservation of democracy
here too charges of fake news and claims
that the press is the enemy of the
people
worsened by the media's constant
amplification and divisiveness
have so diminished the trust many
americans have in the media
that they instead believe bizarre
anonymous
conspiracy theories on the internet
now more than at any other time during
my lifetime
it's essential that the supreme court
retain
the trust of the nation it may be one of
the very few
if not the only of the institutions in
which the great majority of americans
have confidence
that's why judge barrett's integrity
wisdom and commitment to the rule of law
is so important she will be critical to
the preservation
of the public's perception of the of the
legitimacy
of the court judge barrett wrote in the
texas law review
that quote if the court's opinions
change with its membership
public confidence in the court as an
institution might decline
its members might be seen as partisan
rather than impartial
and case law as fueled by power
rather than reason end of quote
consideration of institutional
legitimacy
has long been a factor in the court's
deliberations
but i would argue that this factor
should be given even
greater weight today as so many of our
other institutions
are diminished and under attack
this would be particularly true were the
court
called upon to decide a matter that
would determine the outcome
of a presidential election in my view
it is of paramount importance that such
a decision
follow the law and the constitution
where it leads
regardless of the outcome and thereby be
beyond reproach clearly non-political
and preferably unanimous
the senate will soon send judge barrett
to the highest court in the land
i'm confident that she is up to the
measure of the times in which we now
live
may god bless her and her family as they
begin this chapter
of service to our nation
mr president i suggest the absence of a
quorum
the clerk will call the role mr
alexander
you
you
mr president senator from south dakota
mr president is the senate a quorum call
yes i would ask unanimous consent that
the question is
mr president later today we will confirm
amy coney barrett to the supreme court
by now i don't need to tell anybody that
she is one of the most highly qualified
supreme court candidates in living
memory
her appearance before the senate
judiciary committee was a master class
in what a supreme court justice should
look like
which is probably why a majority voters
want the senate to confirm this
outstanding nominee to the nation's
highest court
mr president a cnn anchor recently
pointed out that and i quote
in another age judge amy coney barrett
would be getting 70 votes or more
in the united states senate because of
her qualifications end quote
that's unquestionably true but
unfortunately it's extremely
unlikely that judge barrett will be
collecting 70 or more votes later today
because for my democrat colleagues this
has never been about
judge barrett's qualifications democrats
were
never going to support this nomination
no matter how supremely qualified
the individual in question the president
could have nominated the wisest
most outstanding jurists in the history
of the world
and democrats would still be opposing
this nomination
in large part simply because it was made
by this president democrats had their
talking points ready from the beginning
the same talking points that they trot
out for every republican
supreme court nominee the sky will fall
if this nominee makes it onto the court
they cry
minorities will suffer women will suffer
americans will lose their health care
they've used that one a lot this time
democrats would like to convince
americans that republicans are trying to
confirm judge barrett to the supreme
court
for the sole purpose of eliminating the
affordable care act and protections for
pre-existing conditions
it's a ludicrous charge every republican
every republican in the senate supports
protections for pre-existing conditions
but apparently that doesn't matter
to democrats the truth is mr president
republicans have no idea
how judge barrett would rule on any
particular
obamacare case the facts of each case
are unique with unique legal
and constitutional issues what we do
know
is that judge barrett will approach each
case without prejudices or preconceived
notions we know that she will examine
the facts of the case the law
and the constitution and make her
decision based solely on those criteria
not on her political beliefs not on her
personal opinions
just the law and the constitution
no matter which party drafted any
legislation
in question mr president that should
reassure democrats but it doesn't
because for many democrats their primary
concern in confirming judges is not
whether they will uphold the law
but whether they will deliver the policy
outcomes that democrats want
that's why some democrats are
threatening to resurrect the long
discredited idea of court packing
should they return to the majority
they're not sure that they can rely on a
supreme court with judge barrett to
deliver the policy outcomes that they
want
so they want to add justices to the
supreme court until they can be sure
that they'll get
the results that they desire
one has to wonder where this will end
let's say democrats add three more
justices to the court
then when republicans take the majority
back we add three more justices
to counteract the democrats power grab
then democrats get back in power and add
still more justices
it won't be long before the members of
the supreme court are more numerous than
the members of the united states senate
mr president in addition to trying to
scare americans by suggesting that
republicans are trying to take away
americans health care
democrats have also tried to
delegitimize the process
they've tried to suggest that it's wrong
for republicans to take up this
nomination
in an election year because republicans
didn't confirm
merrick garland when president obama
nominated him
in an election year mr president i'm not
going to spend
a lot of time on this because the
republican leader myself and others have
spent ample time demonstrating that
confirming judge barrett is
well within historical precedent
but i will say this the constitution
of the united states gives the senate
the power to advise and consent to
nominations made by the president
the senate has full authority to accept
or reject
the president's nominations at any point
in time during a congress
or president's term there is no
constitutional carve out for election
years
the minority party may not always like
it when the majority confirms a nominee
which i completely
understand having been in the minority
myself
but that doesn't mean that the majority
party is doing anything wrong by
proceeding with a nomination
i also have to ask are democrats
seriously suggesting that if they were
in the same position
if they were a majority in the senate
and the president
were a democrat that they would decline
to approve a qualified jurist to the
supreme court simply because the vacancy
had occurred
in an election year i think everyone
knows that if democrats were in the same
position
they would absolutely confirm a democrat
nominee to the court
as they repeatedly urged us to do in
2016
and they would be well within their
constitutional rights to do so
just as republicans are well within our
constitutional rights to confirm
judge barrett mr president before i
close i'd like to touch on another claim
the democrat leader keeps making that
judge barrett's nomination is somehow
distracting republicans from the covid
crisis
or that her nomination is preventing us
from taking up covet legislation
mr president that is flat out false
the senate is capable of focusing on
more than one important issue at a time
in fact it's pretty much a requirement
of our job that we'd be able to do so
has a democrat leader forgotten that
republicans tried to bring up additional
coveted relief legislation
literally just days ago and that
democrats
led by the leader filibustered it
and that they did the same thing we
tried to bring up covert relief
legislation
in september republicans have been ready
to pass additional covert legislation mr
president
for months the only reason we haven't
passed it already is because democrats
have refused to agree
to any compromise legislation could
actually make it through
the senate and to the president's desk
i'm hoping that sooner rather than later
my friends on the other side will see
the value in working together to deliver
real relief to our fellow americans
this disease doesn't recognize party
differences
and i'm hopeful that my colleagues will
realize that passing coveted relief
shouldn't be a time for insisting on
partisan
priorities mr president it's unfortunate
that judge barrett's nomination has been
overshadowed by
so much partisanship from democrats
but ultimately mr president what matters
is that we are confirming this
outstanding
nominee as i said yesterday i came to
the senate
with the hope of putting judges like amy
coney barrett on the bench
thoughtful intelligent men and women
with a consummate command of the law and
most of all
most of all with a clear understanding
that the job of a judge is to interpret
the law
not to make the law to call balls and
strikes
not rewrite the rules of the game
mr president i am very proud
to cast my vote to confirm judge barrett
and i look forward to calling her
justice barrett in the very near future
mr president i yield the floor and i
suggest the absence of a quorum
the clerk will call the role mr
alexander
you